nach dem motto bei uns komplett
auseinandergenommen hat mein geld
einbehält und mir quasi die möglichkeit
genommen hat videos zu machen denn den
nicht unmengen an geld verschenken habe
ich eine lösung gesucht wie ich das
vielleicht doch machen kann deswegen
habe ich jetzt ein placement angenommen
um das geld an euch zu verschenken so
wir brauchen iphone macbook air von
apple lodges im prinzip alles was apple
hat
wir sind im saturn das pack im
schlaraffenland ist fühlt sich so ein
bisschen an wie die fernsehsendung
damals wir laufen jetzt hier durch und
greifen was immer wir wollen und
verschenken das an euch wenn du dir hier
eine sache aussuchen können das was wir
zu nehmen
[Gelächter]
sie können sie auch uns aussuchen
wirklich
irgendwas haben nein nicht beim nächsten
mal 3
heute die garantie auch vor weiteren
menge aufgefallen
beim iphone
[Musik]
dieses video sollen danke seien an jeden
einzelnen von euch ihr habt das jahr zu
dem gemacht was es ist und ich möchte
mich eben auch bei den leuten bedanken
die mir auch an anderen stellen unter
die arme deswegen hat leo was bekommen
und deswegen bekommt man z
ich würde dich bitten deine apple watch
zu studieren ich hab es völlig erledigt
warum bekommen weil danke für deine
unterstützung
durch
eric mein lieber vielen dank für deine
zukunft
das fühlt sich so surreal an ich habe so
viel technik gekauft dass es wirklich
schwer fällt das zu tragen oder hoch zu
halten es ist unglaublich und all das
wird an euch verschenken alle geschenke
sind eingepackt und jetzt heißt es dass
sie genau bei den richtigen leuten
ankommen nämlich bei euch wir haben im
letzten video einen hinweis versteckt wo
man das erste geschenk finden kann und
die weiteren hinweise findet man immer
eine instagram story um in den nächsten
tagen wird es noch völlig verrückt ja es
ist wirklich völlig verrückt ich habe
beispielsweise ein brandneues iphone 12
soweit weggeschmissen wie ich konnte
aber das war kein problem der in rainer
schild ist wie er vermutlich ist die
marke für smartphone cases dass die
höhen sicher sind wurde schon diverse
male gezeigt als sie aus dem helikopter
geschmissen wurde nicht mit dem motor
darüber gefahren bin oder valium unter
einem panzer begraben hat das muss ich
euch also nicht mehr bereit mittlerweile
gibt es unheimlich viele designs mit
blättern künstlern sportverein eurem
lieblings franchise aus film und
fernsehen endlich marvel star wars oder
violett wenn euch das aber immer noch
nicht reicht ist es vereinfacht das
aussehen der verschiedenen cases selber
zu wechseln um die hüllen genau so zu
gestalten wie er es gerne möchte
wechseln der farbe des bankers der
facebook seite oder der knöpfe ergibt
quasi unendliche gestaltungsmöglichkeit
so ist garantiert für jeden von euch
etwas dabei und auch wenn ihr eine
komplett geschlossene hülle haben wollt
bei der es keine austauschbaren teile
gibt ist natürlich gesorgt darüber
hinaus gibt es auch genau passende und
super einfach zu installierende screen
protektoren und kamera projektoren damit
euer handy einfach länger hält und
niemals aussieht wie mein altes gerät
was ich komplett ohne schutz genutzt
habe also klickt auf den ersten blick in
der video beschreibung könnte ich eine
hülle und spart mit dem coach dave 15%
ich bin super dankbar dass rainer schild
verrückt genug ist solche videos mit
währungen zu setzen und mir komplett
freien lauf zu lassen ich hoffe das
wären 20 22 noch öfter zusammen kommen
denn diese freiheit bei videos zu haben
ist wirklich unbezahlbar und ich bin
absolut überzeugt von den produkten
jetzt viel spaß weiter mit dem video
geschenke aufstellen von euch finden
lassen jetzt wird's richtig geil das
video mit dem ersten hinweis geht online
an minute sieben im video ist der
hinweis das bedeutet voraussichtlich
dauert das sie minuten bis die leute
losrennen dann noch mal 15 minuten bis
die ersten leute hier sind haben jetzt
erst mal 20 minuten reich und dort oben
verstecken wir das handy
hier oben liegt das erste geschenk ich
bin gespannt wie lange die leute
brauchen bis sie kommt das ding ist halt
keiner weiß dass fast alle geschenke
mehrere hundert euro wert sind es wird
ein absolutes fest und das dank euch es
hat nicht mal 15 minuten gedauert bis
erste wird
jetzt lieber noch mal herzlichen
glückwunsch und
vielen dank ihr ins wort geil
zweites paket direkt am stadtgarten
mitten in köln in einem baum jetzt heißt
es wieder warten und ich denke dass
schon der ein oder andere mittlerweile
jetzt auf den socken ist und es macht so
eine box war so bock
[Musik]
letztlich doch dann würde sich das
einfache und
darüber die nächsten schritte werden
jetzt wieder kaputt ist eine person ist
immer die schnellste die bekommt das
geschenk und die anderen alle die zu
spät kommen gehen leer aus aber ich hab
mir da was einfallen lassen für alle die
nichts bekommen haben macht man schnell
großstädten an honig aus dem auto
der bisher am anfang oder ich weiß nicht
1 1 am anfang ich schere dass alle rein
kommen
[Musik]
zurück was wir hier ich hab gedacht
papier oder das heißt was man so
reinkommt numerisch wie machst du nicht
noch mal alles ein bisschen flog
zumindest im autohaus aus
der scheiße
du kannst ja aussuchen kleines mittleres
oder großes geschenk nur von der größe
ohne zu wissen was drin ist musst du
vorher ja ich mache mittel ja
vor weihnachten bruder durchaus park
herum aussieht ein bisschen nach
im vollrausch und die leute auch negativ
kommen angerannt nogi verrückt
woraus der platz wir sind ordentlich
weit entfernt vom letzten spot haben
gemerkt dass ich alle leute daran jetzt
um diesen letzten spot getummelt haben
deswegen sind wir ordentlich weit weg
gefahren und jetzt gucken wir wo wir das
ganze im platzieren können das leben ist
die leute machen wir einfach halten
jetzt geht es darum dass wir schneller
sind als die und dass sie dafür unter
sich entscheiden
ohne dies weiter
es gab keine möglichkeit für mich das
geschenk versteckt alle leute waren
direkt hinter mir und hätten natürlich
gesehen wo ich das geschenk hinten also
muss ich mir was einfallen lassen und
hab's einfach auf das nächste vortrag
geschmissen
natürlich komplett köln sind wir im rat
hin und her ich muss noch nicht ob jetzt
total nervig und findet dass wir durch
das game
wie sie
ja ich hab so bock ich hab so bock das
letzte mal die leute haben sich so krass
gefreut jetzt heute wird es noch mal
richtig kann wir haben uns diese nämlich
ein tourist überlegt ich habe die leute
an eine falsche stelle gelaufen eric
wird dort stehen und mit den leuten
quasi die schnitzeljagd bestreiten damit
wir sehen von direkt am anfang haben wir
können sehen wie die losrennen und so
weiter und wir fahren jetzt einen
anderen ort in köln und werden dort die
geschenke platzieren das bedeutet alle
müssen gemeinsam richtung geschenken es
wird krank
[Musik]
stehen dass leute
okay sagte stark
[Musik]
okay geht wieder los
oh
mein gott es geht los jetzt sind sie
kommen gleich alle von hier an gesamt 24
sekunden
wenn sich das hier so ein bisschen
beruhigt hat und die leute dann nicht
mehr darauf achten dann ziehe ich dieses
brandneue iphone 12 aus einer tasche
raus und werfe das so unendlich weit weg
und der erste der leichen rennt kommt
[Musik]
aber setzten sich lassen sich hin wer
vorbeugen
und die leute nochmal anderen
kostenlosen
sie könnten sich zeit auch einfach
nehmen da kommen zwei radfahrer sind ich
glaube doch doch doch
entgegen
nachher ist es
soweit sie hier erinnert ihr euch noch
an das iphone am anfang aus dem video
genau jetzt ist zeit auf den ersten kann
sich das iphone abholen
[Applaus]
herzig und vor weihnachten dankeschön
diese gruppe ist natürlich reiner
deswegen vielen dank dass sie dieses
video hier unterstützen
wollen wir alle euer handy raus und
macht notizen auf ich würde euch bitten
in eure notizen eine zahl zwischen 1 und
100 zu schreiben dann gehen wir einmal
rum filmen das ab damit ihr die nicht
ändern könnt und dann gibt es das
nächste geschenk für die nächste person
okay okay
die zahl war 44
der eine hatte 51 sind siemens werden
dann 35 19
ja der wert aus dem weg räumen ja
im eifer des gefechts passieren fehler
wir müssen sie aber ausbaden wir haben
schon die personen kontaktiert der
eigentlich die airports zu stehen und
die bekommt auch ein paar von uns also
alles bestens navigiere zu mediapark
achtung scheiße
zum glück hat mein auto 460 ps
die fersen
wir wollten eigentlich auf die autobahn
aber wir haben verkackt wir müssen nicht
abhängen
ich werde ihn nicht mehr los ich werde
die nicht los nein wir fahren jetzt
einfach tiefgarage und dann toppen wir
irgendwo ab da hinten
wir müssen jetzt einfach hier in das
erste rein parken irgendwo ab poppen und
das geschenk verstecken ohne dass sie
was sehen
wir uns aufgeteilt werden die leute
nicht loskommen die sind überall auf dem
rad ins internet kann man vergessen
die ganze reihe jungs wir machen so ihr
habt am meisten gebrandet macht bitte
schnick schnack schnuck jetzt bis 11
ich
danke dir
und während wir uns um alle leute
gekümmert haben die uns hinterher
gefahren sind haben sich max und eric
ganz still und heimlich von uns
abgesetzt um das geschenk an einer
anderen stelle zu verstecken
ich schenke platziert ihr habt hier
sehen wo es weil sonst niemand niemand
es uns gefolgt na ja so könnte es hier
versteckt sein
ich weiß halt nicht mal wo das geschenk
ist ich weiß
da kam schon der erste jäger da hinten
er ist schlau der guckt in alle
mülltonnen ich fühle mich so aufregt
filme und mehr findet man mit mir dann
ist man schaut hat das gros der ist
schon jemand an den mülltonnen und du
kommst nicht vor dem
wir haben
[Musik]
einfach im
text du dass der typ der da jetzt die
xbox gewonnen hat mediapark predigt wird
hast ja ja ja der hat sich gedacht so
hätten platz und köln wo groß ist und wo
was sein könnte hat sich hingesetzt
jungs wartet auf mich
wir haben es mal einen längeren
autobahnfahrten tatsächlich geschafft
jetzt die leute abzuhängen damit es
wenigstens zum abschluss noch einmal ein
letztes geschenk mit absoluter
chancengleichheit ist und nicht nur die
leute gewinnen die am meisten renten
sondern auch leute die glücklicherweise
einfach zur richtigen zeit am richtigen
ort finden und hinter kleber plant eines
der legendärsten restaurants in köln und
genau hier wird das geschenk jetzt
produziert und egal wo wir waren
natürlich ließ auch hier der gewinner
nicht lange auf sich
steger
ersten blick gering bild
key wird sich wohl
weihnachten guten roto was gut
wäre ein unglaubliches video geht zu
ende ich weiß gar nicht was ich sagen
soll viel spaß an alle gewinner mit
teuren geschenken vor weihnachten viel
gesundheit ich hoffe da kommt alle
gesund mit der familie zusammen und wir
sehen uns im nächsten video wieder los
[Musik]